that's our vision you know we are going
to enable this industry by providing a
platform that um
most everybody will be using
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders we are
talking about autonomous vehicles and
the enablement of the industry
with reliability meet ziv binyamini the
ceo of fortelix ltd
zev is the ceo of italics a company
dedicated to autonomous vehicles
verification and safety he is a
world-renowned verification visionary
with more than 30 years of experience
previously ziv served as corporate vice
president at cadence running its
simulation and verification business
he also served as vice president of r d
at vericity and at intel leading the
development of coverage driven
verification solutions that change the
way semiconductors are tested
[Music]
ceo for telex welcome to 20 minute
leaders all the way from sunnyvale
california how are you
i'm very good thank you thank you so
much for joining me today and we're
going to be talking about you know some
of the most exciting things that are
happening today in the world of of
technology and and consumer behavior and
autonomous vehicles and autonomous
driving and you know there's there are
some companies that you don't
necessarily see in the forefront
but they're they're the enablers of this
industry for telex is one of them and
helping company helping deploy
autonomous driving systems and and i'm
excited to learn more about fertility
and your journey and and really where i
want to get started
is
is the entrance to fortalex
you know there are some people that have
been dreaming of of the autonomous
vehicles from the the jetsons and from
cartoons when they grew up is that your
case did you always know that you're
going to be
working as a ceo of a company in the
autonomous driving space
not whatsoever
never dreamt of it uh
no i uh
i started i was always uh well
not a geek but i loved software and
mathematics but
started my career in
semiconductor chips
and somehow because of
maybe a coincidence or because of my
love to logic and philosophy i
i got in this space of verification
which is how do you test
all of the possible
situations and i i worked at intern in
my first 10 years of my career
and i was
part of uh
i did several things but always around
verification how do you verify a cheap
um
just to illustrate you know in intel
during the days i was there had uh
one of the early pentium chips called
the pentium pro p6
which was the most complex chip ever
created this was in the
mid 90s
and we had to invent like
there are so many different things that
can go wrong
um
you had to invent new methods of how to
do verification
in an automated way so that you don't
miss any bug
the previous chip that was before us
had
probably the most famous bug ever
in chips
it's called the pentium bug or the f div
bug the floating point divide bug it's a
very rare situation extremely rare
situation which by the way we found
in-house using the methods that
we invented
intel once this bug became public intel
had to recall all of its
chips it cost somewhere between half a
billion to a billion dollar
in the mid 90s which is
hard to imagine that's the cost of a
single tiny little bug
um
so i worked at intel uh and then i
joined the startup called vericity that
uh
basically create the ways to do
verification of chips everybody today if
you go to any company that's
they're doing a semiconductor chip like
apple or intel or nvidia
they're all using the methods that we
invented you know
some time ago
uh this was very successful i worked in
this industry but we always had the
feeling
that those methods that we invented
which allow you to test
an
infinity we call it taming infinity the
number of scenarios in a chip in a with
a three billion transistors is just
infinite how do you still test it
sufficiently
so there's no bug none
it's impossible well we figured out a
way to do it
and we always felt other places where
this could be applicable
and then about five years ago we started
seeing this autonomous world coming and
you're saying wow i just want to jump in
here for a second i'm saying you know
i'm thinking back to the the pentium bug
and you're you know the the cost of an
error on a human you know to the human
level of our experience is
vastly different when you're talking now
and i'm imagining where you're taking
here when you're talking about
verification of chips and we're seeing
these you know these weapons driving you
know at 80 miles an hour in the streets
of the united states it's a little crazy
exactly so these weapons as you call
them you know it's a
several tones object which is moving you
know
even if it's 20 miles an hour
any tiny little mistake can cause a lot
of damage and harm in life and and all
of that
three million lives are lost every year
from accidents and most of them are due
to human errors the driver the human
rival
so if there was a way to do it
it would be save a lot of life and but
those systems are the complexity of
these systems
like just imagine this these uh weapons
you're describing
they have um
more than a hundred chips on a single
autonomous vehicle
more than 100 million lines of code
software
and machine learning
you know several of the main
subsystems are operated by machine
learning which is extremely powerful but
completely unpredictable
so how do you verify this thing this was
our
the start of the journey we saw okay
we should switch from these
chips
to autonomous because
we think we can help we can enable this
industry to actually
become viable with safe you know safe
autonomous vehicles that
with our help we can tame infinity we
can take test all of these infinite
possibilities
and put those same things so that you
know we can reduce the number of
accidents we can you know allow
the elderly have their own car and drive
when they want
because right the driver will be
autonomous etc so there are a lot of
many usages to this technology it's
coming definitely take me back
four years ago
what's happening how how do you make
this transition i understand you know
obviously now it's we can rationalize
through the importance of this but what
was it actually like to make this
dramatic change in your career and to
and to go into this industry that i'm
assuming at that point
you know you're seeing the vision of
what's going to happen but you're not
yet immersed in autonomous vehicles as
you know as a as a job and as an
experience
you know for me
and and my friends you know the partners
to found this company
first of all i had i have to say i had
no feel i
i i had no doubts that you know this
will work and i'll just go there there's
like but in terms of changes there were
massive
one for a personal you know being a ceo
is very different than any other role
so this was uh
one big change another is this
technology of autonomy
and the other which for a business
company
you know we know the semiconductor
industry extremely well we've been there
for decades
uh but going to automotive by the way
it's not just automotive companies like
caterpillar and john deere
you know that you don't think they are
not automotive but they are building
autonomous driving systems tractors and
whatnot so
but these are very different they work
at a different clock cycle they are the
life the
development cycle is much longer
uh etc so that's a huge change and
we need to keep the balance all the time
between bringing all of the knowledge we
have
and it's very valuable this industry i
mean it took time but we have a lot of
proof now that this industry really
um respect what we are bringing at the
same time we need to respect this
industry it's very different it's very
new
um
and by the way we are talking about
autonomous
systems
it's not like there are a lot of people
that have done it quite frankly nobody
have done it yet
aidas you know he does is
semi
it's driver assistant so that's already
deployed but the other things are mostly
you know way more right here
next to where you live
um
they are driving but it's not in
deployment right so
billions and billions of dollars are
invested in this technology but it's not
in deployment yet
so there's nowhere to just
it's not that you're taking an existing
flow and extinct product
and just optimize it no nobody figured
out how to do it and we think one of the
main obstacles
to get safe
scalable deployment of autonomous
systems on the road
is what is called in the industry the
long tail
the long tail of bugs or the situations
so they already work 99.9 percent of the
time okay
but you know one tenth of a percent
means that every you know every thousand
miles you'll have an accident and
unacceptable
the level so you need to find this long
tail those things that will happen only
once in a million miles if you have a
fleet
of a hundred thousand cars
if you have a bug that happens only once
in a million miles it will happen every
you know
every day
right
so
yeah a lot of changes a lot of new and
we always have to keep the balance of
what we know
what we bring keep it and you know
leverage and bring it out
but also constantly learn new things
which by the way is
this is one of the greatest joys of this
job
is that i'm learning so much all the
time it's it's
it's really i can only imagine beyond
beyond learning about the technology
learning about this complicated industry
one of the most complicated
endeavors that honestly humankind is has
has attempted you know this is much much
more complicated than than sending a man
to the moon and to do some of the crazy
things that we've done we're actually
talking about changing transportation
for good and once it's deployed it's
deployed uh it's going to be very hard
to recall this and especially from a
consumer behavior standpoint
now now zev how are the rest of the
players in the market reacting to a
company like forte alex
if you're looking at like the likes of
elon musk and and and the folks at ed
waymo you know what how are they
rationalizing through
what you're describing here is an
opportunity to potentially fix
this long tail of bugs
first of all i have to say that we have
decided to focus on the traditional
automotive industry first
actually not just traditional
our go-to-market strategy is to go to
the
sub-markets of autonomy where there's
actual
deployment
so ada data systems correct and um you
know we are working with volvo on mining
on trucks operating in mines that's
public
so
the car the robot taxi that will operate
in the most complex environment in the
city
again
many companies huge companies that are
spending a lot of money here
like waymo and you know several cores
and algo etc zucks
this is not our main focus right now
we're building the technology our
solutions
where we need to make business so we
need people who are ready to also pay
and and bring in
um and how are those people in the in
this in in that market reacting those
that are already starting to leverage
autonomous vehicles but not necessarily
in this complicated environment that
you're describing that the big players
are fighting over with billions of
dollars
yeah they're also putting billions of
dollars they know that um
look the way you test uh i'll
oversimplify it but the way everybody
tests autonomous systems
is
to the most part they put they put the
software on the system and they go and
drive and they drive and drive and drive
and drive
tesla is using their
customers to do some of the driving i
won't get into that
uh waymo have a fleet of cars and they
drove you know more than 10 million
miles etc
but
people know that this is not scalable
and look we're talking about software
i know if you
software every day you make a new
software fix you fix the bug you add a
new feature you need to run everything
but you can't nobody can drive and 10
million miles within a day or a week
there's just no way to do it right you
need to do it in software you need to do
it
in simulation
you need to do it with synthetic look
one of the things you need to test
is
accidents or near accident situations
right
but these don't happen very frequently
in real life thanks god right
so even if you have a fleet how many
times you got to
almost run into a pedestrian thankfully
almost never but when you test this
autonomous system
you need to do it very very thoroughly
all the situation the pedestrian was
going from the left from the right
you're very close there was rain there
was this speed that's been
infinite number of situations
so everybody that the funny thing is
everybody realize they need something
else they need to move to
do most of the testing in virtual
testing because physical testing will
just not be scalable
and not allow you to test all of the
really difficult dangerous situations
but the move is very slow
right the move is very slow i have to
say in the autonomous in the automotive
industry
we have been working in the last three
years on a standard language to describe
scenarios
so scenarios are the basis right we're
talking about infinite number of
scenarios somebody cuts you from the
left somebody from the right the speed
the this and that
so we suggested to the industry a
language that's some of one of the key
things that we know how to do very well
we've done it many times before
it's a software language it's a machine
and human readable language and this
language is now becoming the basis for
the standards so actually
if you look at acceptance this is
probably the most important standard
for the autonomous industry and it's
based on our
concept our approach and actually our
specific language that we have
implemented
so i think there is a lot of acceptance
but this industry is moving slow
there's also nih not invented here
in some companies um which which is fine
it's you know i've i've
it's not new every the the better the
company the more it believes that it has
all of the solutions and it doesn't need
help from outside
and it's a natural process so
we have patience yeah
take me through you know in in short you
know
if you're looking
a little bit into the future
specifically with fertilics and the
autonomous driving world
where where are we at you know what
where do you where do we want to be
where do you think
for telex with what you're doing today
what is the potential for it in a mature
autonomous driving world that i think
everybody agrees we will get there we
just don't know exactly when
well i think for the industry so this is
happening the adoption of autonomous
systems is happening already
again aidas which people dismiss
especially here
in the bay area they don't consider it
autonomous which i think is a joke
uh it is autonomous and it does more and
more functions but it's not fully
autonomous it's not level four
level three is already getting it's
starting to be there
um and there is deployment all over
again we are talking with we are working
with mining there are many different
sub-markets verticals where this is
being adopted so if you ask me when
there will be a robot taxi in san
francisco i don't know three four five
ten years i have no idea where is
fertilis going to be whenever we have
yeah so so look we have we have the
probably the most critical ingredient
of how to make this system safe and
efficient
which is
the most critical barrier that's the
main reason why waymo is still not you
know everywhere it's about safety it's
about making this thing safe
and i think we have the
the critical uh ingredient our platform
is the most critical enabler so
i don't think we'll be the only player
but i think we will be one of the major
players for this industry and that means
you know
look companies are spending
um in very complex systems in general we
saw it in the chip industry half of the
spending is in for testing validation
same here
there's already predictions i saw some
mckinsey um
analysis that says that for complex
systems level three four five
half of the spend and we're talking
about billions of dollars is going to be
on the testing on validation on ensuring
this system are safe
and we are going to be one of the most
important providers not the only and by
the way we work with many other partners
in the market
in the ecosystem
uh so that's our vision you know we are
going to enable this industry by
providing a platform that
most everybody will be using
phenomenal that's that's where we are
going i i want to thank you not just for
these 20 minutes but for all the great
work that you're doing and eventually
for for making the roads safer
and for making generally things safer
throughout your career and i think it's
such an important role of uh you know
what you're doing and i have to say that
i haven't heard much about this role
until now and i think that's that's not
right and so i'm especially honored to
to be able to share this story through
this platform and and and and to have
learned about it myself and this is
exactly exactly why i do this show and i
really and i and i i really appreciate
it so thank you for sharing your time
with me and best of luck with fertilis
and stay safe and stay healthy
same for you thank you thank you have a
good day thank you
[Music]